an easy way to extend the life of your
car is through proper and regular
maintenance Findlay Toyota the sponsors
of this next segment are ready to assist
when it comes to car maintenance
alignment is key now how can you tell if
your alignment is off if you're driving
and your car pulls to the right there's
an issue the solution Findlay Toyota
[Music]
hey Zeus buddy what's going on man how
are you Jesse how's it going to see you
man oh nice to see you too so today
we're talking about alignment and I know
one of the ways to tell your vehicle
alignment is off is is if your car pulls
to the right or left what are some other
ways to tell that your alignment is on
well we have some handling situations
where your car can feel a little bit
stiffer we also have Tire wears an
indicators so let's say we have the
inside of the tire wearing out a little
bit more than the outside we can have an
indication of some of the measurements
being off how does tire alignment get
out of whack well you can be going down
the road if you're going over too many
potholes or you know where we have a
situation where there's an impact or
suspension component where is also a
cause for an alignment to go out of spec
and why is it important to fix it so if
your car is pulling to the right I think
some people are just kind of like okay
I'll just steer to the left a little bit
why is it important then to get that
alignment oh yeah we have handling we
have our braking we also have tire wear
it can be expensive down the road if you
don't address an alignment a
preventative alignment a maintenance
alignment can save you money down the
road and that's what you guys do here so
someone brings the car in what's the
first step what do we do well we get the
car on the rack we put the sensors on it
they allow us to see what the
measurements are on the vehicle we have
a procedure where we roll the car back
and forth and we do what's called a
Caster sweep to allow us to get the
measurements on the vehicles so that's
what we're seeing right now you have
those hooked up on the tires and that's
what we're seeing right now talk to me
about these numbers that is a live
measurement of where the alignment specs
are for this vehicle usually the machine
will give us different colors the red is
obviously a bad thing okay that needs
more attention but we can always get
this within spec every vehicle has
different specifications we have that
information in our programs and we get
the vehicles within spec and you guys do
obviously Toyotas but you service all
kinds of vehicles we do everything under
the sun you know we have the specs here
for all of that stuff these numbers here
negative 12 negative 11. what are what's
something that's really really bad well
if I were to see anything let's say a
one point something that that's a spec
on this toe specifically that's a spec
that's very off you can can have
premature and severe wear on your tires
because your tires would be too far out
or too far in depending on whether it's
positive or negative someone brings the
car right here how long to get it fixed
and back on the road usually within an
hour to an hour and a half is our is our
time frame between coming in and getting
the car done we like to service our
customers we like to get the cars done
fast we like to get them we respect your
time so that's something that's very
important to us if you come to us if you
happen to hit a car or you know a
pothole on the and you're scared your
car starts driving a little funny hey
let us check it out we'll check it out
for you we'll let you know if it's just
an alignment issue if it's something
else but we'll make sure you're safe
driving down the road you guys are the
pros
we're here for you thank you appreciate
everybody fantastic see you next time
thank you to Findlay Toyota for
sponsoring this segment they are located
in Henderson for more information you
can call
702-566-2596 or visit findleytoyota.com
they have a wheel alignment special for
99.95 for the month of January we'll be
right back